I swore to myself that if I became a
lecturer I would never more my students
that that was a worse sin than almost
any other a teacher could commit was to
be boring today on the podcast the film
experience in this episode we'll explore
what it takes to reframe historical
artifacts things like classic plays
books and films for a modern audience
and I said to him what did you actually
think Shakespeare's environment was he
somehow had managed to disconnect the
literary power of Shakespeare from the
fact that it was done on this incredibly
popular stage and it was so sensational
and it was so much more like television
or the movies than it was like some
process of sitting in a in a library in
wood-paneled splendor reading words in
silence that's not what Shakespeare was
[Music]
how can we compare media so that
students today might better understand
what it originally was
welcome to chalk radio a podcast about
inspired teaching at MIT
I'm your host Sarah Hansen from MIT
OpenCourseWare my guest today is a
longtime professor at MIT I'm David
Thorburn I'm a professor of literature
and comparative media I've taught the
film experience for 39 years at MIT
we'll be talking about professor Thor
Byrnes class 21 l01 won the film
experience and like all of the classes
we talked about on this podcast you can
check out the film experience on OCW
website at ocw.mit.edu professor
Thorburn made a splash in the academic
world by bringing in media that
traditionally hadn't existed there we'll
start with how this all came about
and what it was like for him to
challenge what might be considered
unholy in the sacred space of the
classroom the story of what made me into
a film scholar or a media scholar is at
least interesting to me and so it still
surprises me I had been teaching at Yale
for
for seven or eight years and I was
offered a chance to do a visitation at
the University of California in Santa
Barbara and I was trying to introduce
the students to the idea of conventions
what it means when you begin a story
once upon a time and every story begins
that way or what it means when you say
they lived happily ever after to take
the simplest example of what a
convention is I was trying to illustrate
how in fact we internalize these things
and we understand the conventions of the
narratives of our own time in our blood
without even thinking about it
so what I needed to illustrate the
principle were shared texts so I began
by asking them this was in the 1970s in
the early 1970s and I asked the students
there these are bright california public
school students how many of you have
ever seen a John Wayne movie maybe 15%
of the students raised their hand then I
said well how many of you have read
Huckleberry Finn maybe 30% I tried other
novels classic novels I tried
Shakespeare plays I was at a lot member
this is in the early seventies finally I
said how many of you have seen all in
the family for those in the audience too
young to know this all in the family was
a television program a classic and
transforming one that appeared in 1971
on American television and involved a
working-class hero who had never such
characters had never appeared on
television before was a very important
program and of course a hundred percent
of the class had seen it and I began to
take my examples from television
programs and I became either this [ __ ]
maybe I worried on me as the term went
on and I what I realized was that the
literature of our own day the story
forms that belong to my students and to
the generation of kids I was teaching
were visual not literary
so I became interested in television as
a narrative medium and then I came to
realize as I began to think more
seriously about the role of television
in American like remember by 1970
American television was the dominant
form of entertainment and narrative in
American life and in fact this initial
understanding out of which my whole
interest in media developed has shaped I
realized now just in talking about this
my way of teaching the film experience
when I got back to Yale after my years
visitation I introduced a course called
literature and popular culture in which
I explored these ideas in greater depth
I read some bestsellers I ended the
course by looking at the honeymooners
and I remember I was teaching the course
in a room at Yale College Kalindi
Chittenden Hall in which legendary
figures had laid lectured on Shakespeare
and one of these legendary professors
the man who had actually hired me at
Yale Maynard Mack of great a great
literary scholar poaches headed and
while I was teaching the honeymooners
and then later called me into his office
and expressed great disappointment over
the fact that I was polluting this this
environment so then I and when we then
had a serious conversation and I said to
him what did you what did he actually
think Shakespeare's environment was and
that was when it struck me how narrow my
education had been because he really had
not even though he was a great man and
agreed he knew the history but he
somehow had managed to disconnect the
literary power of Shakespeare from the
fact that it was done on this incredibly
popular stage and it was so sensational
and it was so much more like a
television or the movies than it was
like some process of sitting in a in a
library with wood-paneled splendor
reading words in silence that's not what
Shakespeare was
[Music]
part of why we wanted to talk about
professor Thor Barton's film experience
class is because teaching film changes
as technology and student life evolve
I asked him what this evolution means
for the ways in which he presents his
materials his answer start from the very
beginning when I begin the film
experience I asked the students to do
something they find increasingly
difficult in the old days before the
proliferation of smartphones and visual
media all over the place and everyone
being able to make his own video and so
forth and the you know the ubiquity of
DVDs before those days I was able to
tell the students look we live in an
audio-visual age we live in a televisual
age I want you to think that stuff away
I want you to get think yourself back to
an age before people understood that
there is such a thing as a film and
think about the original meaning of
movie is go back to the roots meaning
it's a metaphor that is a dead metaphor
for us but it actually it's it tells you
what the most fundamental aspect of the
movies were for the original audiences
and why they were so fascinated by the
capacity of this new technology to
capture motion it seemed like and it was
a tremendous new advance in technologies
of the representation of human
experience because it captured humans in
motion it captured the movements of the
world the first films as I try to show
my students were so preoccupied by this
wondrous capacity of the medium that
it's almost the only thing they filmed
and you can see the evolution of the
medium embodied in the way in which
after an initial profound fascination
with the novelty of movement begins to
wear off other properties of the film
medium begin to be discovered so I tell
my students this principle and I asked
them to try to think their way back into
the attitude of these first viewers who
didn't know about the visual media to
play a kind of thought experiment today
it's much harder to make them play that
experiment because I have to tell them
as I do in that first lecture think
away your iPad's imagine a world without
iPads imagine a world without
smartphones imagine a world without
instant communication and of course this
is much harder for the students to do
and of course at one level they are much
more capable of processing audio visual
information than I am and then my and my
parents generation and then and and all
of the generations older than their
because they've grown up in an
environment in which essentially they're
surrounded 24/7 by audio visual stimuli
by audio visual signals this many people
might see this as dangerous perhaps it
is but it develops new capacities and
the and one can see this in the history
of television in which at a certain
point there are certain kinds of
television programs that become too
complex for older generations and only
the younger generation that was used to
going to the movies and had been
watching television and had been
watching MTV they were able to
understand this very easily
professor Thor burns class includes a
two-hour lecture with one more hour of
discussion in our conversation he talked
about the changing popular opinion
surrounding lectures namely that their
outdated and less effective than other
styles of teaching in short he disagrees
I'll let him explain I've thought a lot
about what it means to lecture to
undergraduates I hated bad lectures I
thought they were the the pits of higher
education and I swore to myself that if
I became a lecturer I would never more
my students that that was a worse sin
than almost any other a teacher could
commit was to be boring and I have also
felt that in recent years especially
although it's always been an
undercurrent in education there's been a
kind of growing negative feeling about
lectures as if they're they're hurting
students into a herd experience and it
doesn't give them hands-on experience
and I think intellectually that's a
foolish perspective professors know more
than students it's appropriate for
students to listen to professors
sometimes professors should take the
responsibility of taught when they talk
to students
very seriously and in the in a small
classroom they should certainly
encourage discussion and interaction and
I think at my best I'm not sure I always
am at my best I know I'm not but when I
am at my best I think I'm doing
something that that can't be captured in
printed form or couldn't be captured if
you gave the students a transcript of
what you had done which is that I'm
modeling thinking I'm modeling how you
make connections it seemed to me as I
thought about the most inspiring
lectures that I had as an undergraduate
there was one professor I had especially
he's now dead but he was a wonderfully
inspiring man's name was Lawrence
Holland his lecturer was on American
literature and his strategy in lectures
I've tried to copy one thing he always
did was he presented an outline it
wasn't it was not the text of the
lecture but it was three or four central
digestible points that organized the
lecture in sequence it didn't capture
the whole lecture but if you could use
that sheet to organize your
understanding of the lecture I thought
that was a wonderfully helpful I found
it wonderfully helpful but the both for
review but also because what it showed
me was that Professor Holland had
planned what he was doing that he was
presenting material to me that he had
thought long about that he had organized
in a serious way but the second great
thing about Larry Holland's lectures was
that they were not completely written
out there were parts of them that were
written out very eloquent moments often
at the beginning at the end and I've
sometimes imitated that but the greatest
part of his lectures with his lecture
seemed spontaneous even though he was
following his lecture it seemed as if he
was not he was speaking to me and I
tried to capture I've never been as good
as he was there was a kind of passion a
kind of feeling in what he did and I
realized that the another aspect of what
he was showing me was how not just
intellectually engaged but how
passionate
engaged how emotionally valuable
studying literature could be maybe the
most telling feature of this course is
its intended outcome for students
professor Thorburn isn't trying to
create film critics or even experts in
his classes his school is much more
significant one of the ways of the study
of literature the study of film differs
from the study of technical things and
the reason I teach it is that it belongs
to everyone that it's valuable for
everyone not everyone needs to know
about quantum mechanics but I believe
everyone should and if they don't I feel
they're impoverished know how to read a
good story
enjoy plays know how to enjoy the movies
so I feel that what I'm giving my
students is in some sense something even
more valuable to them because it will be
something that they'll have with them
for their whole lives their whole career
one of the things MIT students sometimes
often do not realize is that a very
large number of them do not end up
making their living in the areas in
which they majored but all of them end
up wanting to go to the movies all of
them end up with a capacity to read and
enjoy literature and I hope that coming
out of my classes they'll do those
things with greater joy and with greater
intelligence but one thing I've thought
about that you know I don't know I I
don't I haven't actually said this in in
in my courses yet but I I think implicit
in my film course is an admiration for a
certain kind of achievement an
admiration for a certain kind of artist
an artist like Jean Renoir the great
filmmaker or Monet the great painter
whose Cathedral series I often talk
about in my teaching and I realized that
I shouldn't leave it implicit because I
want to set up as a candidate for their
admiration an alternative
to Wall Street an alternative to
entrepreneurial genius
I admire John Renoir is genius or Orson
Welles is genius or James Joyce's genius
universe is more than I admire what
entrepreneurs do I respect what
entrepreneurs do but I am in awe of what
great artists do and of what great
doctors do what while we're on the
subject we become so preoccupied by what
we might call commercial or financial
success instead of the kind of lasting
success that great art or the practice
of medicine or the practice of Nursing
or dare I say it the practice of
teaching might also embody
professor Thorburn shares additional
thoughts on teaching the film experience
in a series of videos within the
instructor insight section of is OCW
course you can find them at ocw.mit.edu
and while you're there
download the teaching resources from his
course and find so many other materials
shared by faculty across all of the
schools at MIT
thank you for listening we're so glad
that you're tuning into what makes MIT
is such an exciting place to learn
conversations with people passionate
about impacting the world in positive
ways we hope you'll open MIT to more
people by sharing this podcast and OCW
with your own colleagues and friends
until next time I'm Sarah Hansen from
MIT OpenCourseWare
[Music]